PAIGE BAILEY: TensorFlow
2.0 has arrived
with a focus on usability,
developer productivity,
and simple, intuitive APIs.
If you like Keras and
you like Eager Execution,
you will love TF 2.0.
And if you're a longtime fan
of the original TensorFlow,
you'll still have
the low-level control
that you've come to expect.
Over the last few years,
we've added a large number
of components to TensorFlow.
And with TF 2.0,
these components
are packaged together into a
comprehensive platform that
supports machine learning
workflows through training
and deployment.
This TensorFlow 2.0 release
includes many API changes
such as argument reorders,
API symbol renames, and more.
The TF upgrade V2 tool
helps the transition
by converting existing
TensorFlow 1.12 Python
scripts to TensorFlow
2.0 preview scripts.
Let's dive into collab and
see how you would upgrade.
To use the TensorFlow upgrade
V2 script, all you need to do
is PIP install the
TF nightly preview.
Once that's done, you
can preface your command
with an exclamation point.
Here we can see that
we're specifying
an in file, text generation
dot PUI, and the name of an out
file, so text generation
upgrade dot PY.
We hit Shift Enter,
and we're immediately
displayed output
code showing all
of the conversions
that have taken place
due to this upgrade script.
We can take a look at
the report dot text,
and we can also
check to make sure
that the original script has
been modified with compact V1
terms.
That's it.
You successfully upgraded
a TensorFlow model.
Some warnings, do not
update parts of your code
manually before
running the script.
In particular, functions that
have had reordered arguments,
like TF dot argmax or
TF dot batch to space,
cause the script to incorrectly
add keyword arguments,
and they get mismapped.
This script does not
reorder arguments.
Instead, it adds
keyword arguments
to functions that have had
their arguments reordered.
The conversion process is not
able to upgrade all functions.
One notable example
is TF dot NN dot
com 2d, which no longer takes
they use cuDNN on GPU argument.
If the script
detects this, it'll
report to standard
out and in the report,
and you can fix it manually.
For example, if you
have this, you'll
need to change it to this.
Excellent work.
You just learned how to
upgrade your legacy TensorFlow
code to TensorFlow 2.0 with
the TF 2.0 upgrade script.
If you run into any snags while
doing your model conversions,
please let us know by
filing an issue on GitHub.
And if you have any
feedback on TensorFlow 2.0,
make sure to let the team
know by sending an email
to testing@TensorFlow.org.
You can find a link to that in
the video description below.
We're excited to hear what you
think and happy engineering.